ils ont gâté leur public du stade robert
barran les plaisirs oies ont proposé une
véritable démonstration de rugby et
poitiers n'a rien pu faire pour arrêter
les vagues offensives des hommes de
sébastien on cali une victoire bonifiée
sur le score de 35 à 0 belle victoire
avec la manière et puis un contenu quand
même très intéressant un gros volume de
jeu donc je suis très satisfait
effectivement aujourd'hui de la manière
et puis l'état d'esprit des joueurs quoi
le coeur qu'ils ont eu une petite
déception sur quelques actions qu'on
finit pas dès le début de la rencontre
plaisir impose son rythme vitesse
mouvement continuité dans le jeu les
bleu et jaune ouvrent la marque très
rapidement au bout de 20 minutes il mène
15 à 0
puis des fautes se multiplient le match
et saccadé les sanctions tombent
jusqu'au carton rouge donné à plaisir et
poitiers après une bagarre juste avant
la mi temps
[Musique]
en seconde période les plaisirs aux à
main tiennent la pression sur les
poidevin plus disciplinés ils inscrivent
trois essais dont un par le capitaine en
soit le vilain ça fait toujours plaisir
ça faisait longtemps que ce n'était pas
arrivé mais mais c'est pareil une belle
avancée collective de l'équipe un bon
mouvement des gros qui après resort au
large bon voilà je pense que je peux
faire la passe mais on l'aligné pas
l'enjeu j'essaye d'aller marcher
l'objectif il est clairement affichée
quoi maintenant ça va faire la quatrième
saison consécutive que on évolue en
fédérale 2 avec la première saison ça
fait cinq ans bon bah on a envie d'aller
chercher une place qualificative
les six premiers se qualifient après sa
défaite à gennevilliers lors du premier
match de la saison plaisir pointe à la
6e place prochain match dimanche 26
septembre face au havre
[Applaudissements]